hi this is presh talwalkar
see if you can answer this question
which most phd economists could not
you want a free ticket to see an eric
clapton concert which has no resale
value
bob dylan is performing on the same
night and is your next best alternative
activity
tickets to see dylan cost forty dollars
on any given day you'd be willing to pay
up to fifty dollars to see dylan
assume there are no other cost of seeing
either performer
based on this information what is the
opportunity cost of seeing eric clapton
is it zero dollars ten dollars forty
dollars or fifty
dollars give this problem a try
if you want a hint you can keep watching
the video and i'll explain what the term
opportunity cost means
opportunity cost is an economic term
that refers to the value of the next
best alternative
in other words it's referring to the
value of the opportunity that you didn't
take
one example is suppose your team selects
one player with the first overall draft
pick the opportunity cost is the next
best player that the team didn't pick
or imagine you have an extra ten
thousand dollars that you put in a
checking account and it doesn't earn any
interest
your opportunity cost would be the
foregone interest if you put the money
in a savings account or if you put it in
some other investment
so what's the opportunity cost of seeing
the air clapton concert
the next best activity is seeing bob
dylan
so we need to calculate the value to you
of the bob dylan concert
now you would be willing to pay up to
fifty dollars to see dylan which means
you value the bob dylan concert at fifty
dollars however you have to pay forty
dollars for the ticket so your net value
to the bob dylan concert would be the
ten dollars above the ticket cost
and that's the opportunity cost if you
see eric clapton it would be the ten
dollars of value that you're not getting
if you had gone instead and bought a
ticket for the bob dylan concert
so
how did phd economists do
in 2005 there was a survey of about 200
phds i provided a link to this paper in
the video description
very surprisingly
the correct answer of 10
was actually the least popular choice
the four choices were picked almost as
if they were chosen by random almost 25
percent to each
this was a stunning thing that many
economics phd's didn't have a concept of
what an opportunity cost and actually
caused some stir to say how are we
teaching economics in college
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon
you can catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books their
links in the video description